[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas la contraofensiva
planeada por Ucrania estaría a punto de
entrar en una etapa decisiva el
comandante de las fuerzas armadas de
Ucrania el general Valery saludni
publicó un video en redes sociales bajo
el eslogan es momento de retomar lo que
es nuestro Esta preparación Es evidente
en el frente de esa polilla donde se
cree que las fuerzas ucranianas darán
algunos de sus principales golpes
Catalina Gómez Ángel estuvo con una
unidad de drones en la zona que
monitorea el frente de batalla
la llegada del buen tiempo hace que
transitar por las vías que conducen a
las áreas del frente de la provincia de
saporilla sea más fácil y rápido
tal como lo necesita la unidad de drones
que cumple una tarea establecida por su
comando
en un bosque cercano han localizado una
posición enemiga
estamos preparando para despegar el dron
Estamos buscando hombres que estén allí
y sus equipos la misión requiere que el
dron vaya cargado con una granada que
deben lanzar a una trinchera para eso
deben trabajar rápido y en coordinación
algo que estos tres amigos de infancia
convertidos en militares a causa de la
guerra han aprendido después de más de
un año de vivir en el frente
en nuestra dirección la Infantería del
enemigo se ha incrementado al igual que
su armamento esta región de saporilla
está llamada a ser uno de los puntos
estratégicos de la contraofensiva que
planea Ucrania buscarían avanzar hasta
el mar de asop y cortar el acceso ruso a
la Península de crimea desde la región
ocupada del Don vass
estos drones ayudan a minar la moral y
tienen consecuencias psicológicas en el
enemigo Cuando llegamos a este lugar se
sentían muy seguros nos llevaban y
cascos y chalecos pero gracias a estos
regalos que les dejamos caer tienen
pérdidas y ahora se mueven rápidamente
estas misiones son cada vez más
frecuentes en este otro vídeo se ve como
las fuerzas rusas siguen cavando
trincheras al otro lado de la línea y
cómo gracias al trabajo de
reconocimiento de estos drones logran
detectarlos y atacarlos
ellos no cambian de posiciones sus
mandos no los dejan siempre están
esperando es muy duro desde el punto de
vista psicológico sentarse en las
fronteras y estar bajo nuestros ataques
continuos
la contraofensiva será difícil y los
pondrá al límite
pero dicen que la están esperando como
un niño espera la Navidad
las fuerzas paramilitares Wagner y el
Ministerio de defensa de Rusia aseguran
tener el control de la zona urbana de
batmut Ucrania responde diciendo que
todavía tiene control de una calle y ha
lanzado una contraofensiva en las zonas
aledañas en el norte y al sur de la urbe
en un intento por crear un cerco táctico
alrededor de las tropas rusas nuestra
corresponsal Catalina Gómez Ángeles tuvo
con la brigada 57 que hace parte de esa
contraofensiva alrededor de una ciudad
que pasará ya a la historia como una de
las batallas más crueles en lo corrido
del siglo XXI Esta es una de las rutas
que conducen a las poblaciones aledañas
a bacmut donde la batalla que se libró
en sus calles ha terminado pero los
combates continúan con intensidad en las
regiones que la rodean
estamos en una contraofensiva
lo que hacemos es ir hacia sus
posiciones los expulsamos y las ocupamos
estos hombres pertenecen a la brigada 57
que hace parte de la contraofensiva
lanzada por el ejército ucraniano que es
de hace dos semanas Busca retomar los
alrededores de la ciudad
su artillería trabaja intensamente es
precisa
Buscar refugio en el sótano
subrigado pera en el norte de bakmut
cuentan que los últimos días han
avanzado al menos dos kilómetros en
dirección a la ciudad
Esto es lo que queda debate
todo está destruido Ellos están atacando
continuamente Tan pronto como Ven a
nuestros hombres en el campo o
trincheras atacan por eso es importante
la artillería si no hace su trabajo no
esta Infantería no puede lograr ningún
objetivo en los 10 meses que duró la
batalla esta brigada ha sido enviada a
defender tag mood en dos ocasiones la
última las afueras de la ciudad para que
los ucranianos no fueran encerrados
pero han pagado un alto precio humano
estas pérdidas son muy dolorosas pero
tengo la confianza de que ha valido la
pena
el objetivo de la contraofensiva es
encerrar a las tropas enemigas en
backmooth en lo que los generales
el trabajo que hacemos ahora mismo
podría hacer pensar que estamos
realizando una ofensiva pero lo que
hacemos Es empujar al enemigo para
tratar de encerrarlos allá dentro de
donde se sostienen
sostuvimos su avance lo máximo que
pudimos y ahora intentamos atacar Yo
pienso que será para ellos como un hueso
atravesado en la garganta el tiempo dirá
si Ucrania logró reversar la estrategia
y encerrar a las tropas rusas en la ya
histórica
en medio de la crisis política de
Ecuador vivió un incremento del 66,4% de
muertes violentas en el primer trimestre
del año según datos del Ministerio del
interior y también un aumento del 300%
en extorsiones según la fiscalía
Comparado con el mismo periodo del año
anterior entre tanto la disponibilidad
de medicinas ha ido mejorando hasta
alcanzar un 68,9% para finales del 2022
Pero sigue por debajo de las cifras
óptimas nuestro enviado especial a
Ecuador Rodrigo cedano nos cuenta Cómo
se organizan los ciudadanos ante estos
problemas
cómo me puede ayudar a William basantes
lo paran en busca de ayuda en el popular
barrio de chillogallo al sur de Quito es
el presidente de la Federación de
barrios una agrupación que busca
organizar a los ciudadanos ante la
inseguridad estamos tomando iniciativas
como
colocar las alarmas comunitarias según
datos de la policía las muertes
violentas aumentaron en un 28% en la
ciudad de Quito en todo 2022 de la
desatención del gobierno también crece
la inseguridad parte de su trabajo
consiste además en reunir las demandas
de los vecinos Rosa María Vázquez vive
desde hace 30 años en el barrio
regresar
pronto estamos estamos mal pero no solo
la falta de seguridad afecta a los
Ecuatorianos la desatención en salud
también los aqueja Gabriel orihuela es
el presidente de la asociación de
pacientes del Ecuador una ong que busca
ayudar en el acceso a medicamentos
quisiéramos no tener que hacerlo que el
sistema funcionara bien y que los
medicamentos se le entregaran a los
pacientes en la farmacia hospitalaria
qué es lo que debería suceder
orihuela atribuye la falta de
medicamentos a la corrupción y la mala
planificación del Estado tras el Kobe 19
muchas medicinales les llegan a través
de donaciones de médicos el médico nos
junta todo lo que reciben cierto tiempo
y nosotros vamos a revocar ahora tienden
a unos 1.200 pacientes por todo el país
una de ellas es Michelle realpe vive en
Quito y enferma de lupus desde hace más
de 20 años toma en torno a 10 pastillas
al día La pandemia de Kobe 19 golpeó a
su economía de clase media ahora
complementa ingresos elaborando estas
lámparas aquí me paso puedo pasarme el
día entero sin el apoyo de la asociación
comprar todos sus medicamentos sería
complicado yo cuando tengo trato de no
saturar la ayuda no y le digo Gabriel y
ahora sí Gabriel te pido que me ayudes
esta vez por favor entre tanto seguirá
centrada En esta actividad que le hace
olvidar su estado de salud en Colombia
las fuerzas armadas movilizan sus
recursos en un intento por encontrar a
los cuatro niños perdidos en la selva
tras presuntamente haber sobrevivido a
un accidente de avión Pero además
cuentan con el apoyo de líderes
espirituales y políticos nuestros
reporteros Luis Muñoz Y aitor chavarri
estuvieron en la base militar de calamar
en el departamento del guaviare en la
frontera donde empieza la selva más
espesa
este helicóptero vuelve de la selva
colombiana por un rato lleva días
volando sin parar es parte de la
operación Esperanza que busca rescatar a
cuatro niños perdidos tras un accidente
de avioneta en el que murieron tres
adultos
la familia ha pedido que vayan al lugar
líderes espirituales indígenas y
autoridades políticas de distintas
etnias por eso el gobierno también se
pone las botas como Giovanni julen es el
director de la unidad de restitución de
tierras indígena NASA y organizador de
la minga un espacio para la colaboración
entre distintas comunidades esta minga
que estamos haciendo es muy importante
porque trata de la vida de nuestros
niños se trata de la conversa con
nuestra madre tierra las fuerzas armadas
colaboran para que sean los
conocimientos ancestrales los que guían
la búsqueda un sincretismo desconocido
antes en Colombia en una relación
históricamente basada en la desconfianza
es la misma emoción que despierta el
territorio al que se dirigen una selva
nunca antes explorada por el hombre
repleta de misterios cuando entramos
con miedo porque ellos nos reciben con
alegría nos reciben bien el helicóptero
vuelve a la selva cargado de expertos
indígenas y de la confianza de las
autoridades en que sean los
conocimientos ancestrales los que tengan
la respuesta a la pregunta de toda
Colombia dónde están
queremos agradecer a la pastelería por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa y a ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en France 24 y France
24.com